foreign
we are two moms with little ones uh my
oldest is in second grade so she's in
full-time school public school and it
just it's so great it feels great it
feels great you're like wow that's so
nice our second we'll go to kindergarten
next year and then Charles he has two
more years so then so I feel like we're
kind of seeing the light at the end of
the tunnel of just kids being in
full-time school yeah five days a week
which is great
uh but we've been in that season for
seven years now of me working kind of on
and off depending on the the season
um and and how much travel I have and
you being a working mom now you know
when you have little ones at home there
has to be someone there if you don't
have a spouse that is staying home and
so for a lot of dual income families
which is a majority of Americans a lot
of Americans are a dual income family
you're having to look at options for
child care and it is so expensive we
feel the pain of looking at the budget
knowing what it costs and it's a real
factor and already people the margins
are so slim in life you know because of
inflation and everything we're dealing
with in the economy but also just the
reality of the stats that we know of the
personal finance state of a lot of
people in this country of just living
paycheck to paycheck with Consumer Debt
with wages not going as high as they
were expecting I mean like you know you
you bundle it all together and it can
feel very stressful and you you've
pulled some stats Christina from this
week of some of a survey a study that
came out from care.com yeah there's the
2022 cost of care survey it reveals that
the cost of child care is higher for
families in 2022 51 of parents say they
spend more than 20 percent of their
household income on child care and 72
percent of parents report spending 10
percent or more and they also say that
the quality of child care continues to
be tough for parents to find in fact 43
percent of parents say it's harder to
find Child Care over the past year since
the pandemic and parents continue to
struggle to pay for child care 59 are
more concerned about child care costs
now than a year prior which is driving
significant changes such as taking a
second job reducing hours at work
changing jobs and leaving the workforce
entirely so it's such an important thing
to talk about because I think a lot of
people feel like they're struggling in
this alone they feel kind of overwhelmed
and just kind of trying to trudge
through it but I mean obviously we want
to give hope and encouragement we've
been there I I mean for our family
personally I have a one and
four-year-old we've tried so many
different forms of child care from
Parents Day Out programs to full-time
child care to having a nanny it's like
it's a lot to kind of process and I
think it's so important to just bring
these conversations to light because in
my field I've been talking about college
for years and paying for college and I
see so many families stressing out about
paying for college and
it's crazy to see the studies the
average cost of child care per year for
preschool is similar to the cost of
in-state tuition at a public university
yeah which is wild what's the average
public university right now tuition just
under ten thousand just under 10 000 a
year and that's what we're seeing with
child care happening which is yeah so if
you're feeling that pull that's a real
pull like if you're feeling that stress
and that anxiety that that is a real
thing to talk about and discuss and to
be super strategic and intentional with
that's right and just like anything else
in the budget uh looking to see okay
what uh what are the where are the ways
that we can cut if we can what are the
different options out there that we may
have to plug into different than we had
to three four years ago you know because
life has changed and depending on your
job uh your financial situation you know
this may be an area in your budget where
you say okay what if we look at some
different options that actually may be
able to save us what we're paying now
which possibly could help so there's a
lot of different options out there yeah
for families yeah there's a lot of
different options I was telling Rachel
on the break that even as an
entrepreneur for so many years before I
came to Ramsey my husband and I tried
some non-traditional options for example
I would wake up for a season at 4am and
work till nine and that you know until
my son woke up and then my husband got
off at three and he would take him and
then I'd go back to work and I know it
wasn't ideal but it saved us a lot of
money and it allowed us to have a lot of
time with our son which was great in
what we wanted in that season of life
and then we've tried full-time Care at
other times so it's it is definitely
situation dependent and I think it's
good to kind of explore different
options some people have family nearby
some people have you know friends that
maybe do a nanny share there's just so
many different options versus
immediately signing up for that
expensive daycare that's like around the
block from you for sure for sure yeah
the nanny share thing is huge I know a
few friends that do this and it is
helpful if you're able to split because
you're able to do go a third right of
the cost of what you would normally pay
if you can get two other families with
you if it is something like that and
sometimes it's more convenient like for
yes for some people you know they're
looking at a 15-20 minute commute to put
their kid in a certain program versus a
nanny share might be with your neighbors
where all you have to do is like walk
across the street to take your child to
share the nanny with you know your
neighbors across the street yep and then
there gets to a point too Christina
we've talked to women on the show too
that after paying for child care or even
the commute from where they're working
if they're working outside the home to
somewhere else to this this that they
just say gosh it just it's easier for me
just to go part-time and that I work two
days a week and take that cut because of
what we're saving in child care and in
Computing gas all of it so it's just it
is so dependent per family situations
and everything but um but it is it's a
huge part of people's budget and are
part of our both of our budgets that we
see when it comes to being a mom and
working and so
um yeah it can be stressful yeah and
then also it's just important for people
to explore different options that can
like help with those costs some
employers now are offering benefits for
child care and so that could be a good
conversation if you're looking into a
new job if you have a job and your
benefits are pretty generous you know
see if that's available and if it's not
are they willing to negotiate that into
your package because I mean every little
bit helps if you can get an extra five
to ten thousand dollars a year to help
with that then that's amazing and also
talk to your HR department some
employers offer dependent care accounts
which then you can pay for your daycare
and pre-tax dollars which is obviously
going to be a great savings so just
being really intentional to see what
options are out there you know what
could possibly you know what am I not
thinking about are there any options
outside of the box that could really
make our lives easier and help our
budgets yeah for sure and just to
remember too that you know everything is
a season everything is a season and that
you know these costs aren't unless you
move to like private school and you're
gonna be paying for education at that
point or something kids are expensive
but if you if you're looking at it or at
least I am I'm like okay you know in my
head the amount of years that they're
that they're home and the days I'm
working when I need help versus when
they're going to be full-time in school
right like that that's a season so it's
not going to be that forever expense
That Daycare uh even though that expense
can move to if you pay for a private
school elementary school or something
um but uh and also again I've had
friends that they're like yeah the
pulling back thing is is a real thing
just to say you know maybe it's Child
Care expense and other things uh where
they say hey for a season for this two
years I'm gonna do this a little
differently just to kind of ease the
burden of that of that bill that and
financially we're going to cut the
budget or people that say hey we're
going all in and our and we're just
going to have a tighter budget uh during
the season of having to put our kids in
child care knowing that that's going to
relieve you know have a little bit of
relief here in the next few years yeah I
mean for this season I have a full-time
stay-at-home dad husband which is the
right season for us right now and like
I've said we've been through it feels
like all the different options at this
point and for this season that's what's
right for us that's right and yeah we're
owning it yeah and I think too you know
the the key word here is options it's
options don't just feel like you're
stuck in one thing explore ask people
look at different you know
availabilities whether it's a nanny
share or even a different daycare or
anything to kind of give margin to the
budget if it's needed uh there are
options out there but it can be tough
for sure